[Music]
in gender neutral news okay
submitted by Bart high-five I've are the
parents of a two-year-old are still
refusing to reveal their child's gender
oh did we do this before I don't know
the parents of a three year old set of
parents if we did no gender constructs
sweetie would they don't reveal it to
other people
yeah like the basically they didn't they
don't believe in gender constructs
probably so there's like who cares if
it's male or female the child is just a
child why is it a gay couple or lesbian
or like oh well what other uncle's gonna
call him or her like my name is Nunis
they call them baby but it's not plural
though right but that's how they are
referring to this kid as the same I'm
something I'm just saying not the
pronoun but when they're giving like
your familial title like this is my
nephew or niece which one do they choose
I don't know I think this works
perfectly in a country like the
Philippines where we don't have gender
assignments two things at all Oh mom she
interchanges he and she a lot yeah cuz
she just has no idea what he or she is
it's just that person it's how my cousin
cousin can mean guy or girl like that
yeah it's my cousin is you know in
Spanish like you have you assigned
gender even to object yeah like they
don't we don't have that in our language
so I'm curious to see this Annie a us
call it is you to give it a name that
also doesn't give it away why to be
neutral this is my this is my baby car
Giroux oh wait baby right have you met
tree witch what is that word girl I
don't know well let's get bleep Zoomer
Oh see that's what I'm saying Sumer that
could be anything that sounds more
boyish it does it does yeah Zoomers
boyish yeah they call the kids what does
another gender-neutral thing hold on see
Zoomer done letters easy for short so
this family's from Utah and they are
part of the gender creative parenting
movement okay right there
decided to raise their child without
giving them an agenda or like in a
gender-neutral environment and they the
mom has a blog called raising Zoomer
poor Zoomer you feel good but the mom
could have a gender well yeah I mean
they were already like chosen or
whatever like that's a girl huh they're
waiting for this kid to pick their own
to pick their own and so they're saying
that maybe around age three or four
that's when they're gonna pick their own
gender and then that's when they're
gonna go baseball okay the Christians
are going wild over this one off I get
it
yeah yeah crazy all right oh yeah
that's definitely a girl you think so
yeah yeah so they are saying that
immediate family they do know the gender
but let me tell you something right now
if you guys had a kid we do have a
finality and you didn't tell me what the
identity of the the gender is I would go
crazy down yeah yeah and I would make
you tell me that did you guys have a
gender reveal yeah yeah you did yeah you
were there the pink or the blue spray
the baby shower I remember yeah and your
mom went ham yeah she was she sprayed
you guys down and then she got tired I
remember that as a boy right yeah yeah
Tech is a boy Tech type oh my god
CJ on purpose you know what he's pretty
awful with names that I really am awful
man because I was this close on hating
you but Nobi Nobi I'm telling you
something right now
it took me it took me three years to
memorize your guys's name it's not
because of her I love you guys but I
just as like what's up Geo oh yeah you
know what
you hurt my little ten-year-old niece's
feelings because they've been here for
three weeks now yeah
and when I was we were all in a group
together we were in Disneyland and I was
like hey sweetie um take Isabella to the
bathroom he was like who's ISA Bella and
she was right there and who had spent
every day with her her face was sad I'm
like look it's a [ __ ] grow up you know
I should be more I should be more open
and a nice so type a boy
definitely my mind forever no it's not
I'm gonna ask you in an hour
yeah yeah it's in my mind forever okay
with my name Bart good okay TIFF you Joe
geo I'm bad with names that varies yeah
but you know what the thing is is that
these people are more liberal I think
that's great because look at this yeah
mom says the sex does not tell us
anything about the child's personality
temperament favorite colored dietary
preferences sense of humor attitudes
toward climate change or any other
unique trait so like I wonder hey I
wonder I wonder if they worry about
bills to pay you know I mean like when
people have so much [ __ ] time to
think about all this stuff I'm like do
you have normal people responsibilities
do you you know do you have like career
thoughts or like what's going on that
you have so much extra time to like
think about like the hobby like how
people will have time for their hobbies
I mean maybe it's just a social
experiment they're conducting yeah on
their kids ooh yeah I could relate then
because if I have kids I would like to
teach them assassin skills but not have
them actually assassinate people yeah so
that's a social experiment right yeah or
or I wonder if by them having
predetermined gender I guess identity as
a kid maybe they felt that it held them
back some way so I'm actually interested
in how they feel of what that is I held
them back that they don't want this to
hold their kid like it was a problem
yeah because you know it's like most
parents are like okay I went through
this I don't want my kid to go through
the same thing so for them because they
had predetermined gender identity I
wonder what they're like oh that really
held me back I could have been an
astronaut if I my dad told me that boys
don't like pink but I could have been an
astronaut if I like you did you girls
have penis envy when you were younger I
still do
really I
I did I did a lot when I was younger I
refused to pee sitting down yeah my
parents like sit on the time P I would
just lift my lips and for years yeah I
[ __ ] and V then yeah I did too I'm like
you guys it's just so much more relaxing
sitting down peeing so I would just sit
down and pee a lot but you have an
option to sit down yeah you do you can
sit down anytime you want well I I
always wanted to store things inside me
you can you have Annette smuggled no but
more more than just the [ __ ]
you want your compartment yeah what's
your compartments yeah yeah yeah
Parmesan the water when the balloons of
the heroin riot I guess might be a drug
mule yeah my god what have we done
drugged me all right but you actually
won't have another one here yeah what
you didn't have to be a drug mule if I
was a girl I'd be so [ __ ] cute [ __ ]
I'll be like the Audrey the sassiest
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this side of town no you
yes I would be my ID my lips would be
dangling like this I'm so Lucy just does
this like this it does like a little
thing I look like a like a cartoon
octopus you would not want to male or
female you'd still be shaped like a
boiled egg Bobbi
what's the difference between boiled and
a regular egg or maybe they're all so
[ __ ] the point is is that they're
afraid that what if what if it is gay
and they don't want to you know have the
baby
you have guilt or shame about it so
they're just keeping it completely open
so they could justice choose and not
feel guilt or anything like that I mean
there's always a negative with the
positive no matter what you do yeah I
mean if they're not growing up in an
environment that's already familiar with
that then this child is probably gonna
have a really hard time so hopefully by
the time this child grows up a little
bit more there are monks people that
think exactly the way they do yeah I
think God my parents were like you you
can't make any decisions till you're 18
cuz you're gonna be [ __ ] stupid as
hell cuz it's a hundred percent true no
it tyka that's your baby's name correct
yep no it's Tyco
go kidding take a hike oh yeah hike up
either boy and he said to you hey guys I
think I'm gay how would you feel about
it okay cool
I'm not awesome that's a [ __ ] love it
I love the future I love how open you
are and I love I love that that's who
you are I feel like that's the norm now
what if he goes hey I think I think I'm
black what did you said stuff like that
what well like what if he says like yeah
I think I'm black yeah like you know how
you know like that's the norm now like
yeah you're gay so that's not shocking
like a lot of khabar right then now the
next thing is like oh I think I'm born a
woman right so what's the next thing
like oh actually I think I'm an
intergalactic alien you can't switch
races though if you're going from white
to black like I feel like if it's an
oppressed minority you can't be them you
can't be a Rachel Dolezal then you're
you're trying to live in their history
and somehow in a sick way propel
yourself via all of their hardships
can you go minority in minority no you
can't go mine or me minority of minority
for sure like that like the that white
guy who decided that all of a sudden
he's Filipino Dabu he drove that little
[ __ ] tuk-tuk thing I would say talk
to on TV come on les she has everything
figured out yeah yeah yeah she says she
wants to say what I want to tell you
well they get company peanut beam says
let's say you're my son go ahead and
tell me okay yeah dad I think I'm gay
but I like dick what I think I I like
guys no big help I like them okay I
think I would accept it I have to test
him at first to see how he pushes it
right if you can see I am I am let me
see any pulling at somebody's digging
start sucking I'll be like yeah okay
here's proof that's proof
yeah but also I think that like chicks I
mean just sexual fluidity is less
allowed
you know so I think that you could like
dick at 15 or want to try it and then
not care for it he's such a dick but
you're not gay right
you just curious you know no I was just
I was experimenting in high school and
when I was even middle school so it
doesn't mean you're like fully gay I'm
not gay at all my friend but you just
try it how come in to try so many times
a couple of times why were the ones a
couple of times it's to make sure okay
it's one of those things like you think
you like orange flow and you got to keep
trying to hold a throbbing boner yeah
yeah but that's not out of being gay but
he's not gay you expect for example like
when I was in high school I didn't know
like being gay was a good new thing so I
wanted to figure out if I was gay or not
yeah so exactly what I did okay so what
I did I didn't have to involve another
human being yeah I got myself to the
bone about watching normal porno yeah
then I pulled up a gay porn yeah and
then I wanted to see if I would be even
more turned on or if I would deflate
yeah and then my deflated immediately
saw okay cool I'm not gay and I like
girls and I didn't have to do that
experiment like 20 more time throbbing
[ __ ] in his mouth 20 more times alright
baby it wasn't throbbing it was a kid's
penis oh my god don't see no but I was a
kid too it was another baby
like my friend Greg he's a comic right
he grew up in the past and I'm gonna say
his last name but he told me that there
was that there was a forest where he
knew gay people hung out yeah and he
wanted to see you know he was in his
early 20s maybe I'm gay right see so he
went out to the fore of the sea right
and he went to the forest and a gay guy
came out of the forest and approached
him and cuz you know me to suck your
dick and my friend pushed him and they
just got back in his car and drove away
and he realized I'm not gay so sometimes
you have to do to the go to those
extents yeah but you have to push 20 gay
guys or go back to the forest 2010
[Laughter]
[Music]